it's great to be back from the
thanksgiving holiday here in the united
states
i didn't do much i will talk about it on
the bonus show and the reason i didn't
do much
is with vaccines for coronavirus so
close
why would i do anything at this crucial
time with light at the end of the tunnel
to make the spread potentially
even worse and unfortunately it looks
like it's going to get
really really bad we don't yet have the
numbers that will tell us the impact of
the thanksgiving
travel reportedly almost as many people
as in a normal year a non-pandemic year
flying around for thanksgiving we won't
know the impact of that
in terms of cases for a couple of weeks
and in terms of deaths for a couple of
more weeks beyond that because of the
timeline of
these spike and super spreader events
but even without the numbers that will
be caused by thanksgiving travel and
gatherings
the united states coronavirus pandemic
is completely out of control and donald
trump
insisted in the run-up to the election
that it was all political
after the election you're not going to
hear anything else about the virus
november 4th everything opens schools
everything everything everything opens
obviously this has not happened and the
opposite is actually the truth
in terms of cases per capita the united
states has risen to
sixth most cases per capita in the world
excluding a couple of really tiny
countries and territories places like
andorra which kind of throw off the data
similarly when it comes to deaths using
that same standard the united states has
the seventh highest
rate of deaths per capita
in the world these are horrifying
numbers now in terms of cases and deaths
in the u.s the u.s now has roughly
13.7 million known cases
and 273 000 known
deaths the numbers for both could be
30 or even 50 percent higher as we've
previously described remember
trump said 15 cases will soon be zero
nobody here has died
we might have 50 000 deaths maybe but
probably not
and on and on and on we are at 273
000 nothing is being done at this point
in time
now recall that we had a spike in april
to about 32 000 cases per day
and at the time it looked like a big
spike and then they dipped back down
and then we had a second spike in july
that doubled that up to about 70
000 cases per day and it seemed crazy
and they started to decline but dr fauci
said if we are not careful we will get
beyond
100 000 cases per day in the fall and
half the country didn't believe dr
anthony fauci
and looking at the chart of those cases
those initial spikes now look like mere
mole hills compared to the current
numbers where we saw as many as 178
000 cases in a single day a few days ago
now over the last few days because of
the holiday
combined with weekend uh reporting which
tends to be lower
we see a bit of a dip we expect to see
those numbers
caught up on in the next few days and of
course
it's not just cases it's also deaths
death
spiking we are back up to the numbers of
that
horrible early spike of about 2 000
deaths a day
we even had 2 300 deaths in a single day
last week and it is completely possible
and plausible that these numbers are
going to keep climbing
due to thanksgiving gatherings now
heading into christmas and new year's
there are people who are just determined
to live as if everything is completely
normal
large indoor gatherings it is going to
be insane
now as i mentioned earlier we are very
close to vaccines
we are expecting at this point it is it
is no longer a pipe dream we are
expecting
that there will be people being
vaccinated
on either december 11th or december 12th
december 8 to 10 the fda is meeting with
these
nonpartisan advisory boards to say are
we doing an emergency use
authorization at least for the pfizer
vaccine and then we'll see
if the moderna vaccine it would be
discussed at that same time or maybe
that one will take a little bit longer
if that is the case vaccines are already
being transported united airlines
flights bringing vaccines from belgium
to chicago for further distribution the
logistics are on the move
we are this close we could have 20
million people vaccinated by the end of
december
we could have another 30 million by the
end of january
another 30 to 35 million by the end of
february so what that means is
that in the next three months it's
basically december by in the in december
january february we could potentially
have
80 to 85 million people vaccinated
by the last day of february we are
getting close
this is not the time to behave
irresponsibly
and see this absolutely almost
cartoonish rise in cases dr
fauci saying to martha raddatz over the
weekend
that you could see this looks like a
surge
you could see thanksgiving and christmas
accelerated
even more to a surge upon a surge
let's not do it this has nothing to
trump failed yes
trump failed trump's got days left in
his presidency
let's get this under control because we
are so so close
um and we'll keep you posted on the
numbers and the data but it is looking
very very ugly so far if you love
feeding your intellectual curiosity but
you're always struggling to find the
time check out one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an entire book
on your way home from work they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one into text or audio
that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect if you don't have
enough time
to do all the reading you want to do or
if you just want
to sample a book before you buy the
entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription is only
about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video